[Music]
Russian President Vladimir Putin says he
has new weapons the US cannot defeat and
he says he's not bluffing the Trump
administration specifically the Pentagon
is not impressed
of course Richardson has the alarming
specifics from the State Department
tonight a new Russian nuclear-powered
missile unlimited range unpredictable
trajectory invincible against missile
defense all according to the Russian
government a video animation shows this
missile cruising around international
defences and headed towards the west
coast of the United States standing in
front of that video and boasting of
these claimed advances Russian President
Vladimir Putin is that well with you no
one wanted to speak with us
constructively
no one has listened to us you listen to
us now at his annual State of the Nation
Address Putin also unveiled other
claimed Russian advances the senior
State Department official says it was
deeply unfortunate to watch a video
depicting a nuclear attack on the US and
that it is not the behavior of a
responsible international player we
don't think it's responsible we don't
think that kind of imagery seen the
portrayal and a cheesy video of that
kind of attack being conducted on the
United States as being a responsible
action as for the reality of Russia's
capabilities to US officials say it's
touted new missile is still in
development these weapons that but that
are discussed have been in development a
very long time our Nuclear Posture
review takes all of this into account
Putin delivered these threats in a halt
Emperor Alexander the first built to
commemorate victory over Napoleon in
less than three weeks before Russia's
presidential election President Putin
challenged the West the candidates
permitted to oppose Putin debated
throwing insults and water at each other
Ian Bremmer the president of the Eurasia
group tweeted quote Putin has great
missiles no question he also leads an
economy smaller than Canada's the US
should not be overly distracted by a
Putin election speech and as Russia
continues supporting rebels who are
fighting the Ukrainian government the
State Department has just approved 40
seven million dollars in arms sales to
Ukraine 210 anti-tank missiles and a
significant boost in lethal aid to that
government Brett Richardson live at the
State Department rich thanks